the sponsor car tester Ronnie lipstick
says Spanish car maker see ah - offers
sporty models like the fr and today he's
taking one out for a spin checking out
the fr version of Annie beats a station
wagon Germans like station wagons
they're available in all varieties from
the practical daily models to luxurious
designer estate cars but compact station
wagons like the CIT b2st
are relatively rare in Germany the peppy
little fr version boasts a responsive
chassis turbocharged gasoline engine and
snug seats that make it comfortable for
daily driving
Ronni tells us the CLE BTS TFR has a 1.4
liter four-cylinder engine that's doubly
charged
thanks to turbo technology and the
compressor he says the car responds well
there's no lag it accelerates quickly
and he likes that 103 kilowatts of power
helped the test car to hit respectable
speeds although it's economical burning
just 4.7 liters of fuel to travel 100
kilometers but our test car with a 1.4
TSI engine has a base price tag of over
21,000 euros per tester says the
instrument panels and the CID beats are
well organized and easy to find but the
interior materials trouble him there's
just too much hard plastic the fr logo
decorates the grille the whole front end
is unmistakably Ibiza the fog lights
immediately stand out from the angular
styling the gasoline-powered engine
provides 250 Newton meters of torque
the station wagon version of the cbiit
says 18 centimeters longer than the
others for a compact station wagon
there's plenty of space under the
hatchback a volume of 430 liters that
more than doubles to 1164 liters when
the back seat is folded down shut the
trunk door and the back end is a bit
more modest than the front F R stands
for formula racing says Ronnie you don't
only see it you feel it too says the
steering is very precise and responsive
even when cornering at high speeds that
all makes the CLE beats a stf are just
the thing for anyone looking for an
economical vehicle with plenty of
storage space and good performance a
unites dynamism and daily life the vita
st FR is also much sporty-er than the
normal version of the model little
details distinguish it from its more
sedate cousin including a chassis that's
15 centimetres closer to the road
the only Ronnie says he's convinced by
this unusual combination of compact and
station wagon the say out of beat CST
starts at 12,500 euros in Germany but he
recommends the fr version for those who
want a sporty or Drive